il travaillait en tant que technico
commercial ou dans la chaîne logistique
laura hyart noms ont décidé de changer
de vie pour se lancer dans un tout autre
projet artisans torréfacteur entre
autres travaillé sur la cuisson du café
pour en ressortir tous et à rome en
réflexion depuis trois ans le projet
arlos koffi a vu le jour début mai à
rambouillet on avait quand même ce ce
bagage qui nous sert forcément dans la
gestion de l'entreprise mais par rapport
au café on s'est totalement formés sur
la torréfaction sur l'histoire du café
sur les producteurs arlos koffi
travaille avec du café de spécialité
gage de qualité et d'éthique
le café arrive ici sous forme brute
appelé café vert
voilà comment enfin sous quelle forme
ils sont dans les sacs de toile de jute
donc on a
on a dit qu à fait différent donc une
partie vient d'amérique du sud
d'amérique centrale et on en a deux qui
viennent on d'ethiopie et du burundi
donc en fonction des de la provenance
on va avoir des goûts différents entre
le café vert et ensuite tour est fier
artisanalement à l'aide d'une machine
chauffée à plus de 200 degrés le café
est inséré par le haut
reste à suivre la cuisson du café on
vient vraiment faire notre cuisson si on
veut développer plutôt le côté floral du
brun végétale ou le contraire puisse
partir sur le botté corps amertume du
café est donc une fois qu'on a qu'on est
qu on a réalisé notre cuisson comme on
le souhaite on il a actionné le
refroidisseur avec 2 cuil la partie
refroidissement et palm et du coup
ouvrir le
le tambour pour évacuer les grands arlos
koffi dispose également d'un camion
magasin un coffee trucks
il permet de couvrir les marchés et les
événements locaux les gens en fait
achètent leur café en grains ou ont dû
donc on a le moulin qui est ici qui nous
permet de le moudre directement donc
pour une mouture la plus fraîche la
crèche possible et il ya une partie
aussi services à la consommation
arlon scofi ouvert début mai à
rambouillet 350 kg de café ont déjà été
torréfié